i'm not sure if i know anymore how to
make a video where i don't just have no
script but no notes but i guess they
start out good morning hank it's tuesday
except it's not tuesday it's sunday
night at 11 30. so there's this mountain
goat song i love called you were cool
where the lyrics start out these are the
same four chords i use most of the time
when there's something on my mind and i
don't want to squander the moment
and i guess these are the same four
chords i use most of the time eight days
ago i found out that one of my close
friends from high school died and then
the next morning i found out that dr
paul farmer had died and then four days
later the 15th annual project for
awesome began so this year's project for
awesome happened amid a global crisis
but for me it happened among personal
ones as well it's been a difficult week
for me i hope i don't have a lot of
weeks like this in my life
i'm not sure what else to say about it
there's actually this cardboard cut out
of me that's just off screen here i'll
show it to you i don't know if you can
see it but um
it's me
but i'm like my head's by my feet and
i'm completely
discombobulated and i've looked at that
all weekend and been like
yeah you know like that's uh
that's about how it feels i don't know
what else to say about it it's not very
interesting it just sucks when people
you love die it sucks and you wonder
what you should have done differently
and you wonder
how to make sense of a world where they
aren't but mere despair never tells the
full human story like i am totally
unconvinced by any arguments that there
is something inevitable or desirable
about the inequity and injustice and
unfairness of the human condition and
yes i know that we will all die and
everyone we love will die and eventually
all humans will die but for me that
makes the fact that we pour love into
each other and we experience real
solidarity and we work for a better
shared future for humanity that makes
all of that
more beautiful more wondrous the fact
that we're able to do that even though
we know this is temporary makes it
more amazing and yet it is also true
that we are monsters to each other that
we are all capable of monstrosity and i
don't just mean like the active evil of
killing people and starting wars i also
mean the passive evil the ways that evil
can be this sort of banal bureaucratic
thing where we just pass over human
suffering and treat it like it's
something inevitable to me what is so
heartbreaking and what leads me toward
despair is also where i find hope which
is that there is nothing inevitable
about this when i was a freshman in
college kids were twice as likely
globally to die before the age of five
as they are today that is a massive
human success story this year's project
for awesome raised over 3 million for
charity by almost any measure it was the
most successful project for awesome of
all time including by the measure of how
hoarse my voice is the reason i've been
overwhelmed with grief this week is
because i've been reminded that nothing
happens alone that throughout my life i
have had fellow travelers and people
expressing real meaningful solidarity
with me that made me feel less alone
this weekend during the project for
awesome i was reminded over and over
again of that that even when we feel
alone we never are and that our job as
human beings is to make ourselves and
others feel less alone and to know that
they are accompanied through everything
they will go through all right for my
final chord i want to go back to that
mountain goat song one of the last lines
of which is
we held on to hope that better days were
coming
and when we did
we were right
thank you for an amazing project for
awesome hank
i'll see you on friday